the number two player on the planet
although yesterday's loss kind of upset
things a bit uh
fabi this game you went after him and
you played
incredible amount of preparation because
you were blitzing
every single move when did you actually
get out of theory because it looked like
25 moves in 26 7 was in you were still
well within your preparation
i feel like we were both sort of in
preparation for a long time but we were
both struggling to remember
the details um
the problem is that we we both have an
enormous amount of choices uh
after f4
and bishop b5 which he played as one of
them and i assume
if you play this it has to be you have
to know the position because bishop b5
doesn't really come to mind it sort of
abandons the king
in a sense and
um and he played rook g7 instantly so i
assumed he was
successfully recalling his preparation
what about you how far were you in to
like knowing for sure like the move f7
queen d2 or were you going on instinct
yeah i knew that you played queen d2 and
i didn't really know much after that but
uh
i mean i the position is i guess roughly
equal
um of course that that's only the
evaluation in a practical game why did
you not play queen d2 before f7 uh
before f6 i assume black can take on f5
then at least i was worried that i can
take
uh and maybe queen f7 um
i wasn't
f6 rookie six i had
i don't know but
but i thought that he would have this
option of taking
okay
so now you said you were struggling at
this point
to figure out what to do and uh why did
you choose the path you did um
well it seemed logical i don't want to
allow his queen to get to e6 queen d5
is super logical um
and
yeah i okay bishop b2
i suspect i was expecting
h6 but it he does have a lot of choices
i mean the bishop should get back to g4
and to e6 but
um but the question is what move order
and it's very difficult
um it's actually one of the
the most complicated positions i've
played in a long time in terms of just
trying to calculate things
um
and yeah i think he played h5 which is a
very dangerous move later on
because he can
play h6 i think he's totally fine
here i should play knight c6
because okay now he's much more quickly
liquidating the pawns now 97 is very
dangerous so bishop g4
this would be like in the game
i assume he wanted the pawn in h5 rather
than h6
probably he was worried about 97 taking
bishop d6
which is what i was going to do and i
assumed
that i'm not worse but also
probably
my attack isn't is not is enough only
for a draw queen e7 bishop d6
i think he can play queen g5
and if rook c7 queen of six the queen
uh or
yeah i couldn't can't remember exactly
what i wanted but
but i think i was looking at something
like this but here queen e6 uh bishop
five queens likes 28 wins so
now i don't remember what i was looking
at
um
but okay i understand he he wanted he
was probably worried about this stuff
and
and felt high was more stable
and and now i spent like after h5 i
probably spent like an hour
yeah it was 50 minutes and 23 seconds
because i i have
so many
possible moves okay knight c6 is the
most obvious one threatening 97
bishop g4 is forced i think
97. if he played h4 what did you have i
thought 97 would be very strong um
maybe it's not but take take queen e7
bishop
d6
i think this was the moment where bishop
takes nine
years
of d6 in this moment is winning yeah
oh yeah and yeah actually i did i did
notice this tactic and then um
and then i've seen that yeah right yes
um
but okay i i didn't look at h4 much i
mean i thought bishop g4 is the is the
only move right
which was played
and then how did you no no no this never
happened no he was looking at knight c6
bishop g4 and how did you continue in
your mind well
i have okay 97 didn't seem to lead
anywhere um in my calculations he takes
bishop d6 queen e6 and um
i don't think i have anything end games
might even be a bit worse so i didn't
really want to go for this
um although i i think it should be a
drill and then i have like bishop g4
queen a5
um
but
it looked extremely unnatural and i
thought maybe bishop f3 is a good move
yeah threatens 98
um but
after like 98 bishop before king a1 he
has
rook h7
um
i i thought it's both very risky and
i couldn't quite make it work um
so so i rejected this one
and there's also bishop g4 bishop a5 but
it didn't didn't seem to work out so
um so actually i was also looking at
rook c6 this is a move i probably spent
like half an hour
thinking about
which is very direct i just want to take
on d6
um
actually the reason i rejected it it was
working out in all lines
and then i noticed this move queen h3
and i couldn't find a move there
queen h3 wow
wow
because now i abandoned my first rank so
after bishop d6 he has bishop d3
king a2 queen f1 and i get mated
that's awkward
so then i saw this happening in my mind
and i thought okay this is this is not
how i want to lose today
um at night c4 i thought
it's safe
um
it's very close to being positionally
winning
okay i mean i spent a lot of time on
bishop b1 uh h3 bishop g3 oh after a
knight c4 take take h4
there should be one it's it's very
tempting to keep my rook alive um
h3 is forced bishop g3
and he's completely paralyzed he only
has one move
to play queen b5 otherwise there's just
no move
and end games are
very close to just being bad for him but
um but i didn't see more than a draw
here because he he'll take on d5 like
let's say i play bishop h2
he's again paralyzed he he takes
i take he plays rook b7 because he has
to do something
um rook b4 rook c7
and i saw this draw bishop g1 rook h7
bishop h2
rook c7
um if he gets active his then his rook
starts to collect too many pawns
uh
and i thought okay
i still felt like i had some
advantage or chances to win so i didn't
want to go for the straw
um
but i ended up confusing myself
too much
trying to figure out the game hasn't
there no draw between samsung and
virtual report we were expecting that we
were indeed
and so we were we were concerned in a
moment when you played what looked like
a deep move king a2
that you had this chance to play instead
of d2 rook h2 yeah after rook h7 i
didn't see your next move uh queen c4
i didn't see this um i i don't
you put it up
just uh waiting
you you mentioned that waiting black was
in a situation that in the past
moments uh fabi queen v5 was a move that
black had to rely upon and this moment
with the rook on h7 the king on h8 queen
b5 has actually met by this very nasty
geometry pleasing move queen c8 yeah he
can't allow this but if he plays queen
g4
queen to g4
we had an answer for that one too
bishop d2
bishop d2
black is just running out of moves to
play
um iron
g3 yeah this
is you see it i'm just like trying to
figure out the wind
yeah king h8
oh and g6 is hanging okay
yes precisely
g6 is hanging and queen b3 doesn't do
anything because i can just
like even to visualize that this is not
perpetual because of bishop c1 would
uh pretty taxing yeah it's it's a
difficult uh bit of calculation um
yeah i don't know like queen c4 didn't i
mean i saw that the move was possible
but i just didn't see the point of it
he's in some kind of zugzwang almost
like he's well his bishop can't move his
rook is tied down his queen's kind of
tied down
maybe or maybe not you're threatening
upon who knows the problem was he was
getting this queen g4 g3 in all the
lines and here i i
basically stopped that because the queen
comes to e60 e8 um
so
so yeah he gets paralyzed and and maybe
i eventually
i'll take a palm but i i just didn't
consider the move so
and the thing is i was also like when i
played rook d2 i had this
kind of vision that
i
rook d2 rook h7 i thought maybe i can
play queen a8 and then i realize that it
just doesn't work for more than one
reason
queen f7 rook d5
um
okay and queen g8 is is the main issue
the most
the most clear-cut uh issue
uh after bishop v6 he can take i think
it's a
i don't know if it's a draw in that case
but i think it's still a draw
um but he can also play h2
and bishop of eight h1 my the queen on
g8 somehow defends everything
that's a pretty funny position
so this this was important um and then
okay i had a minute i thought
i can still play rook h2 and then
instead of bishop d6 but
i couldn't figure it out it was very
confusing and
i was low on time and
it was difficult to make this decision
with you know one minute
on the clock to play rook h2 here so
i thought let's shut it down
so you remain a half a point behind
behind the crew
got three rounds to go
still have aspirations of course to win
the tournament
disappointment today maybe an
opportunity lost or is just a game
um well it was really difficult i i
don't think that i missed something easy
it's not like my my game against jeffrey
i
i really felt disgusted after the game
because
i did it all to myself um
i i feel like this was at least a normal
game we were both
calculating a lot and uh
uh and maxime is is really uh at his
best in these positions it is um it is
his main strength uh
so it's it's it's going to be very
difficult to to beat him
um of course i did have
you know the opening went well i i put a
lot of pressure on maybe i could have
hoped for more but queen c4 was a tough
one
one final question for me is yesterday
we were at a pool party
and you and maxine hung out like best
buds like it wasn't any animosity you
knew you had to play the next day this
very important game how is it that
players can maintain that cordiality and
even like straight
up
amicability friendship
knowing that hey money's going to be on
the line when we play tomorrow
yeah i guess it depends on the player i
mean um
you know they're all competitors but
there are some friendships and and i
like maxime he's a friend so
um
yeah i have no problem hanging out with
him and it doesn't affect how we
um you know how we play the next day it
wasn't like we made a quick draw or
anything
um
we i i think we both knew how important
this game was but
uh it was also nice to relax and not
think about chess for a few hours
if i give you sorry because you got me
ralph for a second question forgive me
is there
are there any players
you're not hanging with before today
like yeah most of them
good answer good answer all right well
good luck tomorrow in your game thank
you thank you pappy i we thought it was
a really really great game